et on continue à en parler avec notre
invité Pierre De Jong bonjour vous êtes
ancien colonel des troupes de marines et
vice-président également de l'Institut
Thémis alors ce sont des bombardements
qui rappellent évidemment le début du
conflit quel est le message que Vladimir
Poutine veut faire passer vous avez de
l'aide militaire des Occidentaux mais
nous gardons la main
non je ne crois pas je pense que en fait
il y a un changement de portable
d'ailleurs le président de la République
vient de l'annoncer ce matin
concrètement il y a un nouveau une
nouvelle période qui vient s'ouvrir la
première étant ou Poutine à penser
conquérir l'Ukraine sans couperi en
quelques jours la deuxième c'était un
combat très conventionnel si vous voulez
dans les tranchées avec des blindés etc
ça n'a pas fonctionné non plus là il
engagé un 3 une troisième période qui
est une période extrêmement mortelle
pourquoi parce qu'il va utiliser
l'armement qu'il a pas utilisé jusqu'à
présent en tout cas en grand nombre
c'est en fait il a choisi sa stratégie
devient stratégie anticiter en civil
antipopulation et ça on l'avait
absolument pas prévu ce n'est pas entre
guillemets prévisible en tout cas c'est
pas admissible et donc ça c'est un vrai
changement et là il pense pouvoir en
fait modifier le rapport de force et
arrêter la progression ukrainienne et
puis simplement asservie ou en tout cas
affaiblir suffisamment l'Ukraine pour
que l'Ukraine demande la paix ou en tout
cas demande l'arrêt des hostilités alors
selon les l'autorité ukrainienne l'armée
russe attirée ce lundi 83 missiles dont
environ la moitié aurait pu être
intercepté qu'est-ce que ça dit de
l'appareil de défense de l'armée
ukrainienne
je pense qu'il a mis ukrainienne n'est
pas du tout préparée pour arrêter ce
genre de d'attaque son des salles de
missiles puisqu'on parle de 73 et
peut-être 100 ou 200 en fait on en sait
pas grand chose donc je pense que le
encore une fois le l'Ukraine n'est pas
n'est pas prête si vous voulez à ça
d'autant que les Russes on fait des
démonstrations pendant les six pour les
mois de la de la guerre où ils ont
démontré si vous voulez qu'ils avaient
fait des progrès très importants dans le
domaine de la des missiles et surtout
des missiles hypersoniques donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui on sait que les
batteries antimicides n'arrêtent pas des
messies les personnes qui vont à plus de
10000 km à l'heure donc c'est presque
impensable donc aujourd'hui on n'est pas
prêt donc le problème c'est la réponse
la réponse elle peut venir théoriquement
que d'Occident et et de l'OTAN et on
sait aujourd'hui que dans le cas de la
non comédie gérance l'OTAN est
particulièrement les Américains
n'accepteront pas d'intervenir alors
Joe bidona est intervenu il y a quelques
minutes à peine et il promet au
président Zelenski des systèmes
perfectionnés de défense aériennes
est-ce que ça pourrait changer la donne
sur le terrain est-ce que ça pourrait
permettre à Kiev dès qu'il recevront ses
appareils de de d'intercepter de mieux
maîtriser cette guerre alors oui bien
évidemment c'est le système patriote qui
était déjà vendu à Israël qui a créé ce
qu'on appelle le Dôme de fer donc c'est
fonctionnel évidemment mais ça n'arrête
pas tous les missiles oui encore une
fois ça peut ça peut limiter si vous
voulez les intrusions à base de missiles
sur le territoire ukrainien alors voilà
déjà plusieurs semaines que la Dimar
Poutine a lancé la mobilisation des
réservistes on avait beaucoup parlé à
l'époque 300000 hommes devraient être
appelés ce qu'on sait que si trois
semaines après il y a eu un changement
sur le terrain le poisson c'est pas ce
qu'on sait globalement c'est que ce 300
000 hommes il a bien cent mille qui sont
formés même si 200 000 ne l'était pas ce
qui a été plus ou moins prouvé donc
encore une fois les 100000 qui ont été
injectés dans les dispositif si vous
voulez renforce bien évidemment les
forces russes et on peut s'attendre si
vous voulez dans les jours qui viennent
à une espèce d'offensive ou en tout cas
un espèce de résistance des forces
russes par rapport à la pression
ukrainienne je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
pression ukrainienne assez CC ou en tout
cas elle a diminué donc on va on va
aller progressivement vers l'hiver un
espace de culpabilisation du front
terrestre alors que moi je pense que les
problèmes liés aux missiles et les
attaques si vous voulez le troisième
dimension vous augmentez puisque les
conditions climatiques vont le permettre
merci beaucoup pierre de jongle ancien
colonel des troupes de marines et
vice-président de l'Institut Thémis
merci d'avoir pris le temps d'analyser
la situation avec nous ce soir sur
France 24